[Music]
brook randy moved down here in florida
to start a new life they were always
laughing swimming
balling
always having fun he wrote with brook
they were like brother and sister
9-1-1 emergency you need to send police
someone's been murdered
i'm sorry
it was me
all i remember is standing over top of
her and i'm holding a knife in my hand i
don't remember anything that just
happened something was off about this
case when the police questioned randy he
was remorseful about what had happened i
definitely felt that he had profound
amnesia for the event and then there was
certainly a lack of motive
he's very kind friendly there didn't
seem to be any logical basis for this
crime i would have walked away saying
there's nothing had i not asked that
last question have you ever sleepwalked
breaking news a killer is using the
surprising defense of sleepwalking
as a child one night randy rode his bike
to the bar i knew he was sleepwalking
because he didn't speak to me
certainly there are sleepwalkers who
seem to do very coordinated scary things
randy admitted being awake when brooke
got there is this what he actually
remembers or is this what he thinks
makes sense to him
randy who is absolutely in love with
brook preston brook was stabbed 25 times
it's almost impossible to wake up a
sleepwalker the alcohol he was something
that would make people more apt to
sleepwalk
your life was spiraling out of control
that's correct she said randy was naked
and that freaked her out
the question here tonight remains why
there's a growing concern we're going
gonna see more and more of these kinds
of problems potentially anyone can be a
sleepwalker
someone can kill somebody in their sleep
under the right circumstances
[Music]
[Music]
you